deux informations ponctuelles ce matin
pourraient laisser penser que le numéro
1 est allemand a réussi à stopper
l'hémorragie en ouvrant le mur au cours
des dernières 24 heures seulement 605
est Allemands se sont réfugiés en RFA or
tous ces derniers jours c'était 10000
quotidiennement de plus selon la
Croix-Rouge de plus en plus d'Allemands
de l'Est qui avaient quitté leur pays
rentrent aujourd'hui chez eux la
Croix-Rouge parle de milliers de
personnes mais revenons au grand concert
de cette nuit un concert pour Berlin
auquel particip Nina la chanteuse de
rock originaire d'Allemagne de l'Est
reportage de Corine
per soirée choc pour les est allemands
en visite à Berlin Ouest une ninaen
provocatrice à
sou de quoi commencer à combler une
frustration vieille de 30
ans je peux croire croire
ça
fille de l'est passé à l'ouest nen
incarna hier soir l'unité de Berlin
enfin
retrouvé je désire que les Allemands de
l'Est a de nouveaux partis de nouvelles
organisations politiques comme ils l'ont
d'ailleurs toujours désiré et puis des
élections officielles pour le
Parlement un vote
libre que les partis qui sont encore
clandestin puiss être au grand jour tel
que mon propre parti le FRH les
féministes radical harmonieuse un parti
d'importance
mondiale
après 3 journées de folie les Berlinois
de l'Est ont repris le travail ils ont
refait la queue à la frontière mais
cette fois pour rentrer chez eux revenir
de l'Ouest une sensation qu'on ressentit
pour la première fois ce weekend 2
millions de berlinois